michel audureau et ses poules c'est
toute une histoire 25 ans qu'il pratique
leur élevage dans sa basse cour
familiale dans le sud touraine en 2012
il avait publié quelques uns de ses
conseils dans un premier livre il
revient aujourd'hui avec une nouvelle
édition largement complété
les poules n'ont pas changé mais notre
rapport aux animaux a changé et ça c'est
fondamental entre le début du mois
j'avais l'impression de faire attention
bien natation mes animaux et aujourd'hui
avec toutes les questions qui sont
posées sur le bien-être animal on
s'aperçoit que c'est pas si évident que
ça premier de ses conseils à l'éleveur
amateurs offrir un maximum d'espacé à
ses poules une clé pour conserver un
élevage en bonne santé quarante mètres
carrés par poule en tout 40 mètres
carrés
la terre se chargeant un pathogène avec
les fientes et la nature peut pas les
régénérer or les poules
consomme apple dans ce cas consomment
dans la seconde dans la journée qui est
à peu près 20% de terre donc on comprend
très bien que année après année elles ne
font qu'un but est de plus en plus de
pathogènes et il ya des maladies ou dans
faverolles gâtinaise noir du berry ou
comme ici géline de touraine sont autant
de race typique de la région centre ce
livre regorge de conseils pour choisir
entretenir et soignez vos bêtes et puis
il ya aussi le poulailler vous saurez
tout sur les modèles les plus adaptées
acheter ou à construire par vous même il
s'agit simplement que d'un endroit pour
bien dormir affirme éthique mais
ventilés et
sur un tout petit peu les yeux on peut
mettre six poules ans est par contre
ouvrir le maintenant fermé sous l'arche
est impératif pour les prédateurs avoir
un poulailler bien douillet bien choisir
ses poules offrir de l'espace et un peu
de votre temps
soyez en sûr vos gallinacés sauront vous
grande